i am here to sign a document betting ten
thousand dollars
that my last video is in fact correct
this is the video in question some
people may have missed it
but in this car there is no motor no
batteries
no energy source besides the wind itself
and the counter-intuitive claim
is that this car can maintain speeds
faster than the wind that's pushing it
there is a physics professor at ucla
who got in touch to say that he thought
that i was wrong that the explanation
was wrong
you know we went back and forth a little
bit and eventually i said
well how about we bet ten thousand
dollars
i can prove it to you this vehicle
really can go downwind faster than the
wind
and to my surprise he is taking me up on
the bet look no no one is perfect
uh but you have a much lower error rate
than most
uh people on youtube in youtube space
now professor alex kusenko wanted this
wager and
all related discourse to be public in
fact he suggested we get a celebrity to
witness the signing
so i asked neil degrasse tyson bill nye
and sean carroll to be our witnesses and
they graciously agreed
and alex i just want to say uh i agree
with everything you've said about
veritasium
that i'm generally i can watch it and
not have to wonder
is he going to mess up how am i going to
no he's brilliant
i'm excited about this bet because if i
am wrong then i want to know
like the whole point of the channel is
to get to the truth and
that is i think why we're all here today
and i think you know this is a great
great chance to sort of
see i'm going to summarize alex's main
points in this video but i'll put
his full presentation here so let me
first explain
what i see in the video in the video
the vehicle is operated in a gusty wind
initially you have the wind speed are
exceeding the car speed
but then the wind speed is not constant
the wind speed drops
and the car moves by inertia with
deceleration
for a while so basically alex thinks a
gust pushes the car to a high speed and
then when the wind dies
the car is going faster than the wind
momentarily but it must be slowing down
in fact that will be my conclusion at
the end of this presentation that
whenever you have
velocity faster than the wind i'll
actually show you in an equation
the acceleration is negative the second
effect is that
the wind in the individual is measured
at the height of about a meter or meter
and a half but the propeller goes to
some
three meters above the ground now due to
interactions with the ground
there is a wind gradient wind travels
slower
close to the ground and then faster
higher up now alex estimated that the
wind speed of the propeller might be 10
or 15 percent higher
than at the telltale so it's possible
that the car could be moving slower than
the wind at the propeller
and yet appear to be moving faster than
the wind at the height of the telltale
now i think that this is a small effect
however
in combination with the previous effect
it just can make this more
frequent okay and that completes um
if i remember the video correctly
derrick reports
that they've achieved up to 2.8 times
wind speed
that feels much higher
than what is possible here unless the
wind had picked up and then
spontaneously sort of dropped very very
good question okay
if you're going for the record you
probably will do many attempts
you will be sampling that that gusty
wind over
and over and over until you set the
record right that's how you set the
record
and on one of those occasions you will
get a nice strong gust
which is three times the app that comes
after it okay
and that's when you will clock the
record and that's where that
2.8 factor will come in so what about
the treadmill tests
these are conducted in still air by
moving the ground backwards you're
simulating a perfectly steady tailwind
and if you hold the car stationary on
the treadmill well that's equivalent to
the car going exactly wind speed
now if the car can move forward on the
treadmill
that shows it can accelerate faster than
the wind
but alex had multiple explanations why
these experiments
don't actually show what they claim to
show if you have
uh this uh you know fluctuating speed of
the treadmill
and then if a human just sort of steers
it it then can introduce unconsciously
a bias towards the desired result so
what it may be
that the guy with the spork is inducing
the
model craft to go across the wing now
and then
so
yeah i'm sure i'm 100 sure that
uh the guy in the in the video doesn't
do it uh on purpose
okay yeah however you know if he is
expecting
uh forward drift yeah right yeah
absolutely yeah
that's that's what exactly okay so you
go in the absence of convincing
experimental evidence
alex turned to theoretical analyses like
one by mit arrow professor mark drella
but here too he found problems his main
concern is that the equation for net
force
includes the difference between the
speeds of the car and the wind
in the denominator which seems to imply
that when traveling
exactly wind speed you should get
infinite force
now here's a real danger because if
if derek drives very close to the wind
that difference
in speed goes to zero if it's one
millionth
of a one percent that's like a nuclear
bomb exploding behind him
then derek is definitely in trouble
right so we need we need to
find something to save derek's life here
this is this is serious right
but dividing by zero come on you guys i
never looked at that
alex performed his own analysis and
found no such divide by zero problems
in fact he found there's no way for the
cart to accelerate
at or above wind speed the acceleration
of this craft is negative so when we
you know so it's possible to move the
craft faster than the wind but it's not
possible to move it
at zero acceleration which would be
needed to maintain constant
speed that is basically where we left it
right thank you neil thank you very much
guys thanks dale
so now it was up to me to convince
professor kosenko that blackbird really
can go faster than the wind
but his presentation was effective when
i posted about it on twitter
alice zhang who runs chinese veritasium
said i think you lost derek
i'm 80 on alex's side now what's amazing
to me is that neither one of them
had seen my attempts to replicate the
treadmill experiments
for the first video i asked my friend
and youtube maker xyla foxlin to make a
model downwind
cart
version one ended in failure but xyla
was undeterred
coming back in a couple days with
version two is it feeling like it's
gonna
unlike these models most of her projects
actually work
she is determined so maybe this tells us
something
about whether you can actually go faster
than the wind
downwind what was clear to me is that i
didn't do a good enough job in the first
video
explaining how blackbird works and
providing convincing evidence
that it can really go faster than the
wind in a sustained way
in my defense i thought the concept was
well enough established
way back in 1969 andrew bauer built the
first
successful downwind cart and he did it
to settle a friendly wager with aero
engineer apollo smith
the bet was inspired by a claim in a
student's paper from 20 years earlier
now rick cavallaro the builder of
blackbird was completely unaware of all
this until after he built his cart
but other analyses have been published
under names like the push me
pull you boat so i didn't honestly think
anyone would doubt the
vehicle's operation much less bet me ten
thousand dollars
but clearly there is a need for a deeper
explanation
so i want to do that now by responding
to the points alex raised
so first let's deal with wind gradient i
mean why didn't we measure the speed of
the wind
higher up well the answer is because
it's already been done
they mounted telltales on fishing poles
out to the sides of the propeller and
even above it now although the lowest
telltale flips back first
all of the telltales do eventually flip
backwards showing that
every part of the vehicle is going
faster than the wind
could this be because of a big wind gust
that pushed the car
up to high speed and then the wind died
i don't think so
even though i didn't have a speedometer
in the car for my runs
someone on twitter pointed out that we
could use the rotation of the back wheel
to determine the speed from the video
footage this shows
that even after the telltale flips
backwards the car keeps accelerating
another thing i want to point out is
that if wind gradient or gusts were the
reason that the car travels faster than
the wind
well you'd expect the telltale to jump
around or
at least not point straight back at me
but it consistently does for over 30
seconds
until i had to hit the brakes to avoid
crashing into parked vehicles
but if that's not enough for you when
blackbird achieved its record speed of
27.7 miles per hour
in a 10 mile per hour tailwind it was
still
accelerating and we know this because
there were multiple gps units
in the car and wind speeds which were
measured at the height of the propeller
at multiple locations the highlighted
section shows the 10 second measurement
period
over which the record was set also in
2013 the us
physics olympiad semi-final exam asked
questions about blackbird
like can it go faster than the wind
downwind and
upwind the solution says both modes are
possible
and with sufficiently low energy loss
any speed
is possible now i'll admit that the
evidence i showed in the first video
was not definitive wind gusts or
gradients
could have explained the observations
but now that you've seen
this evidence are you convinced that
blackbird can go downwind faster than
the wind
without slowing down well professor
casenko
was not convinced so i want to explain
how the car works
so clearly that no one not even the
professor can doubt what's going on
the first thing to know is that the
propeller doesn't work like most people
think
it's not working like a windmill it
doesn't turn the way the tailwind is
pushing it
instead it turns in the opposite
direction working like a fan
to push air backwards this fan is
powered by the wheels
which are connected to the propeller by
a bike chain so at wind speed
the car can keep accelerating because
the wheels turn the fan which blows air
back
generating forward thrust now the big
question is
to drive the fan there must be a
backwards force on the wheels which
tends to slow them down
so why isn't this force bigger than the
thrust from the propeller causing the
car to slow down
overall well the answer is the wheels
are going so much faster over the ground
than the propeller is moving through the
air so the thrust force can actually be
larger
i'm going to do an analysis in the frame
of reference of the car
and the important equation to know is
power equals force times velocity
so at the wheels power is input into the
system by the ground moving underneath
the car
the power generated is the force of the
ground on the wheels
times the velocity of the car
at the propeller work is done on the air
as the propeller pushes it backwards
the power out equals the force of the
prop on the air
times the speed of the car minus the
speed of the wind
the prop is going slower through the air
due to the tailwind
and if we assume no losses then the
power in at the wheels
equals the power out at the propeller
from this equation we can see that the
force at the propeller
will be greater than the force at the
wheels
and since the propeller is pushing air
back the air applies an equal and
opposite force
forward on the prop this is the thrust
force which will be greater than the
backwards force
on the wheels so
this car works like a lever or a pulley
by applying a small force to the wheels
over a larger distance
the propeller can apply a larger force
over a smaller distance
this is just like when you're riding a
bike going uphill
you move the pedals fast but with
smaller force to make the wheels move
slower over the ground
but with a bigger force but now we've
run into the divide by zero problem that
professor
kosenko warned us about when the speed
of the car is exactly equal to the speed
of the wind
it seems like the propeller can provide
infinite force
that can't be right can it i mean is our
analysis flawed
the answer is no for two reasons first
of all this is exactly what you'd expect
theoretically with
any lever or pulley if one arm of the
lever is zero then you can
lift an infinite weight with any amount
of force on the other side
the catch is its displacement will be
zero
second of all in practice there is a
propeller efficiency term that is
ill-defined when the propeller is not
moving through the air
there is a better formula for the prop
efficiency which
is well defined in the zero air speed
limit it makes an algebraic mess but
it's perfectly well defined
and then the divide by zero problem is
eliminated
but that equation makes the problem look
more complicated than it actually is
you don't actually need aerodynamics
here i have a little cart with a big
wheel
that rolls on two smaller spools and
what i'm going to show is that when you
have two media
moving relative to one another well then
if this car is in
contact with both media it can actually
move
faster than their relative velocity
so as i push the board to the right
you can see that the car goes down the
board
faster than the board is moving
if you look carefully you'll see that
the big wheel
isn't turning the way that the board is
pushing it
it's actually rotating in the opposite
direction
that's just like the propeller on
blackbird which pushes
back against the air and that's how it's
able to go
faster than the wind downwind
now you can build one of these cars for
yourself at home
or you can build a model downwind
cart i told you xyla was determined yeah
i'm going to make the claim on camera
i like i think it's going to work this
time we're changing the propeller it has
to work before we get kicked out of the
treadmill store
does it work it totally works amazing
oh my god it's so good her fourth
version of the cart works spectacularly
and it was designed to be replicated by
anyone using just a 3d printer and a
simple list of materials
she explains how to build it with more
details on the engineering process on a
video over on her channel so
go check it out now professor casenko
has now conceded the bet
and he transferred ten thousand dollars
to me so i want to thank him for being a
man of honor
and changing his mind in light of the
evidence i presented
which is really not easy to do
especially in a public debate like this
one
now i do not want to keep the money i
want to invest it
in science communication so i'm holding
a one minute
video competition i'll be awarding cash
prizes
to the top three videos that explain a
counter-intuitive
stem concept i'll put some details down
in the description
what i love about science is that
disagreements are not
problems they are opportunities for
everyone to learn something
i learned a lot more about blackbird
aerodynamics
and gear ratios than i knew before i
also learned that i should go into more
depth in my videos i should make the
evidence
overwhelmingly convincing and put in
some equations toward the end for
those who want that level of detail i
want to thank everyone
involved in the making this video neil
degrasse tyson bill nye shawn carroll
mark drella professor cosenko
and xyla foxlin but especially rick
cavallaro the inventor and creator of
blackbird
he was a fountain of information a
constant source of support and the man
leading the charge to help people
understand this area of physics for the
past
15 years let's hope this video puts the
issue to rest
once and for all
the blackbird craft all started with a
brain teaser and this video sponsor
brilliant
offers you a daily problem to solve
every day like this one about gear
ratios
if the first gear spins 10 times per
second at what rate does the final gear
spin
now i did this problem the hard way but
my wife figured out how to do it the
easy way
and that's what brain teasers are great
for they get you thinking about the
world and they give you
insights into problems you might think
you already understand
just think about how much more you would
understand in a year
if you got into the habit of solving one
novel unexpected problem per day
and while you're at it why not take one
of brilliant's courses like on computer
science neural networks or classical
physics
even physics professors can benefit from
some lessons on frames of reference
somehow i managed to go my whole degree
without learning lacranjian mechanics so
that's a course i'm working through
at the moment it's a really elegant way
of solving physics problems and i wish i
had learned about it
sooner for viewers of this channel
brilliant are offering 20
off an annual subscription to the first
200 people to sign up just go to
brilliant.org
veritasium i will put that link down in
the description
so i want to thank brilliant for
supporting veritasium and i want to
thank you
for watching